question the second half was now they
sell gears to Microsoft okay so that was
the thing that's one of the things that
that missed me a little bit is the fact
that you know Tim and Mark didn't let me
know you know I actually got a phone
call so Phil lets you know he'll let you
know he's a stand-up dude every time
I've I've met him and talked to him or
whatever I've just he just comes across
as a stand-up guy he really is and
that's that's the thing is you know I
have this phrase I've been using lately
I have a lot of phrases
um establishing character shot right
like and you know when someone shows you
who they are believe them
this goes back to Peter Moore goes back
to Phil Spencer you know they're they're
just stand-up dudes you know Tim and
Mark are as well right and you know
there's the saying about Hollywood it's
not show friends it's show business but
in many ways it is show Friends there's
a reason why you know Steven Spielberg
has worked with Tom Hanks so much you
know you know filming a TV show or a
movie it's a lot of work and you're on
set for for many many hours you know so
you want to be around people that are
you know you you kind of vibe with right
right but you know in regards to the
future you know